Hi.
Hey.
I'm eating.
I'm eating right now.
Hold on.
One
more little noodle.
One more little...
Sorry.
I didn't know you could see that.
Why is there a box on my face?
And the karaoke box over the...
Stop it!
Stop looking!
Actually, I think I need to do the...
You know what?
Screw you guys.
Are you ready to be nice now?
Are we ready?
To party!
Karaoke time!
Yippee!
I don't know what to sing at all.
I have like no list at all.
We're singing whatever we want, baby.
Some things, if they're not on KaraFan, I can probably find them on YouTube.
Andrico, thanks for the 10 gift tours!
Country Roads!
Hey KSTF2, thanks for the 20 gifted!
You know what?
Let's start with a little Country Roads warm up.
Country Roads!
Take me home.
I'll do this as a test.
Sound test too.
Because...
No, no!
Oh.
Oh my god.
So in my...
Almost.
Hey.
Oh my god.
West Virginia.
Blue Ridge Mountains.
Shenandoah River.
Life is old there.
Older than the trees.
Younger than the mountains.
Blowing like a breeze.
Country Roads.
Take me home to the place.
I'll do this as a test.
Stay hydrated, everybody!
Dark and dusty, painted on the sky, misty taste of moonshine, teardrop in my eye.
Country roads, take me home, to the place I belong.
West Virginia, mountain mama.
Take me home.
Country roads.
I hear her voice in the morning hours.
She calls me.
The radio reminds me of my home far away.
Driving down the road, I get a feeling that I should have been home yesterday.
Yesterday.
Country roads.
Take me home.
To the place I belong.
West Virginia, mountain mama.
Take me home.
Country roads.
One more time!
Take me home.
To the place.
To the place I belong.
I'm home.
West Virginia, mountain mama.
Take me home.
Country roads.
Yee-haw!
Yee-haw, everybody.
How was the audio on that?
Oh wait, I forgot to do a set list.
One.
Country roads.
Actually, I don't want it on the... let's do it to the left.
To the left, to the left.
Everything you own in a box to the left.
Audio's perfect, audio's good, sounds great!
Yee-haw, partner!
Yee-yup!
You mighta look and mighta find here today.
Can you sing in Kermit voice?
What would you want me to sing in Kermit voice?
Healing my soul.
I'm gonna move you guys over a little bit.
Actually, I'm gonna move you guys right here.
Yay!
Yee-yup!
And also, I'm gonna block how many people are watching.
I usually do, but...
The way I had it before.
California girls.
California girls are running around...
Thank you, kindly partner.
California girls.
By Katy Perry.
As sung by Kermit.
Kermit voice.
Um...
Okay...
I think you can do this.
Greetings, loved ones.
Greetings.
Let's take a journey.
I know a place.
Where the grass is really greener.
Warm.
Wet and wild.
There must be something.
Sippin' gin and juice.
Let's go.
Playing underneath the palm trees.
The boys...
Break their necks.
Try to creep a little sneak peek.
You could travel the world.
But nothing comes close to the golden coast.
Once you party with Frogbert.
You'll be falling in love.
Oh, oh, oh.
California frogs were unpretentious.
Daisy Dukes.
Bikinis on top.
Sun-kissed skin.
So hot.
We'll melt your popsicle.
Oh, oh, oh.
California frogs.
We're undeniable.
Fine, fresh, fierce.
We got it on lock.
West Coast represent.
Put your hands up.
Peach?
Why is it so bright?
We don't mind sand in our stilettos.
We freak.
In my jeep.
Snoop Doggy Dog on the stereo.
Oh, oh.
You could travel the world.
But nothing comes close to the golden coast.
Once you party with Frogbert.
You'll be falling in love.
Oh, oh, oh.
California frogs were unpretentious.
Daisy Dukes.
Bikinis on top.
Sun-kissed skin.
So hot.
We'll melt your popsicle.
Oh, oh.
California girls.
We're undeniable.
Fine, fresh, fierce.
We got it on lock.
West Coast represent.
I don't remember how this song goes.
I'm just listening to the harmony.
Tone 10.
Batten ready.
Wait.
No
one's happy.
She's all...
She's trying to be friendly.
When it's beach and Palm Springs.
Summertime is everything.
Homeboys hanging out.
All that ass hanging out.
Bikinis, zucchinis, martinis.
No weenies.
It's just the king and the queenie.
Katie, my lady, look here.
Oh, look here, baby.
I'm all up on you.
Daisy Dukes.
Bikinis on top.
Sun-kissed skin so hot.
We'll melt your popsicle.
Oh, oh, oh.
California girls.
We're undeniable.
Fine, fresh, fierce.
We got it on lock.
West Coast represent.
Now put your hands.
There's
only a few children who would do what we do.
I think I lost.
I think I got lost in the sauce there a little bit.
No, I messed up the best part.
I'm so sorry.
One second.
I think I'm going to turn the glow down just a little bit.
So you guys don't keep getting flash banged when it shows up.
Oh my god.
That was California frogs.
Popsicle status melted.
California frogs.
My throat is...
Don't...
Don't tampon ready.
Like me and the frogs, right?
They gotta get frogs out.
Well, not in the summer time.
They... in the winter time.
Don't they hibernate?
Hmm.
Okay.
Thank you for karaoke on my birthday.
Happy birthday KCraft.
Ah.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday KCraft.
Happy birthday...
to you...
Maybe cloudy and rainy out, butpois giglin '' taxes jasme '' singing is all the sunshine I need for What else can we do?
Oh my gosh, the world is our oyster.
We can sing whatever we want.
Trooper by Iron Maiden.
I'm sorry, I don't know it well enough.
Please don't spam though.
If you want me to sing a song, if you spam it, it's going to be even less likely I sing it.
Sorry, the notice.
This is the fat and ready content.
That's so funny.
Let's see.
The title of the stream is English song.
Kermit fat and ready.
Oh man.
Golden hour?
Already?
Oh my gosh, let me warm up a little bit first.
Let me warm up a little bit.
But I'm fat and ready for Frogbert to be my Yoshino.
Paramore.
Oh gosh, what do I know by Paramore?
I know maybe Paramore.
Yes, Golden Hour.
I could try.
Sing Snow Halation has about five English words.
Now I could sing the triple Q version.
Is it Misery Business is the one that I was...
I don't think I know it well enough though.
Do they have duvet?
Duvet?
Is that how you say it?
Oh my gosh, they do.
Okay, I can sing that one later.
I want to do a little bit more.
Mambo number five.
Mambo.
Ladies
and gentlemen, this is Mambo number five.
One, two, three, four, five.
Everybody in the car.
So come on, let's ride to the liquor store.
Let's go around the corner.
The boys say they want some gin and juice.
But I really don't want to be a buzz like I had last week.
I must stay deep because talk is cheap.
I like Angela, Pamela, Sandra, and Rita.
And as I continue, you know they're getting sweeter.
So what can I do?
I don't know how this song is turning.
It's just like a spark.
Anything fly.
It's all good.
Let me jump in and send in the trumpet.
A little bit of Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica.
On my side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Mary all I need.
But you makes me your man.
Jump up and down.
And move it all around.
Shake your head to the sound.
Put your hands on the ground.
Take one step left and one step right.
One to the front and one to the side.
Clap your hands.
One...
A little bit of Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Minto.
It's an endurance stream, that's why.
You're mad!
Drop it!
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Mary all night long.
A little bit of Jessica, here I am.
A little bit of you makes me your man.
To all to fall in love with a girl like you.
Cause you can't run and you can't hide.
You and me gonna touch the sky.
That's kind of scary.
What do you mean I can't run or hide?
I'm kind of scared now.
Yeah, Mambo, Mambo.
Number five.
Four.
This song is a threat.
Monica, Erica, Rita, Tina, Sandra, Mary, and Jessica?
All me.
Sing Jolene!
Oh my gosh.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
I can try.
Dolly Parton.
I think I remember this one.
I think I...
Fleetwood Mac?
Oh yeah, we can do some later.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
Love you, please don't take my man.
Please don't take, take him just because you can.
Your beauty is beyond compare.
With flaming locks of auburn hair.
With ivory skin and eyes of emerald green.
Your smile's like a breath of spring.
Your voice is soft like summer rain.
And I cannot compete with you, Jolene.
He talks about you in his sleep.
There's nothing I can do to keep from crying when he calls your name.
Jolene.
And I can easily understand how you could easily take my man.
But you don't know what he means to me.
Jolene.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
I'm begging of you, please don't take my man.
Jolene.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
Please don't take him just because you can.
You could have your choice of men, but I could never love again.
He's the only one for me.
Jolene.
Is that a JoJo reference?
Actually, the other way around.
My happiness depends on you and whatever you decide to do.
Jolene.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
I'm begging of you, please don't take my man.
Please don't take him even though you can.
Jolene.
Damn, hit it, girl!
That's a Dolly Parton reference.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
Oops.
Jolene.
From JoJo's Bizarre Adventure.
This too is Yuri.
I mean...
Jolene, she sounds like...
I don't know, I can't tell if she's like...
If she's gonna take the...
If she's like interested in the guy or if she's like, you know...
Moana!
I was just thinking I want to sing Disney songs.
Oh my god, I sang this all the time when I was in Japan.
I can't tell if she's like trying to take her...
Take the guy or if she's just like...
No, I know you can do it but like...
Please don't.
But also this guy sounds like a jerk.
He's the one who's like saying her name in his sleep.
What a weirdo.
Oh.
I don't remember which one it is.
If it's the original one or if it's the...
I'm gonna try this one.
If it's the wrong one, if it's like the...
If it's like the...
Poppy version, I'll change.
Break Stuff by Limp Bizkit.
Patience.
I've been staring at the edge of the water Long as I can remember Never really knowing why I wish I could be the perfect daughter But I come back to the water No matter how hard I try Every turn I take Every trail I track Every path I make Every road leads back To the place I know Where I cannot go Where I long to be See the line where the sky meets the sea It calls me And no one knows,
how far it goes, if the wind in my sail on the sea stays behind me, one day I'll know, if I go, there's just no telling how far I'll go, I know, everybody on this island, seems so happy on this island, everything is by design.
I know, everybody on this island, has a role on this island, so maybe I can roll with mine, I can lead with pride, I can make us strong, I'll be satisfied, if I play along, but the voice inside, sings a different song, what is wrong with me?
See the light as it shines on the sea, it's blinding, but no one knows, how deep it goes, and it seems like it's calling out to me, so come find me, and let me know, what's beyond that line, will I cross that line, see the line where the sky meets the sea,
it calls me, and no one knows, how far it goes, if the wind in my sail on the sea stays behind me, one day I'll know, how far I'll go.
Wah.
This song makes me tear up every time.
Makes me so emotional.
How far I'll go.
Because I relate to the lyrics so much.
I don't know.
It's hard to explain.
Disney.
Disney, Disney.
What's another Disney, Disney?
I won't say I'm in love.
I don't know.
Doo doo.
Boo doo.
Boom, boom, boom.
Wait, there's a longer version of this song?
I don't know.
I don't know it though.
If there's a price for rotten judgement, I guess I've already won that.
No man is worth the aggravation, that's inked in history.
Been there, done that.
Who'd you think you're kidding?
He's the year that ever do you try to keep it hidden.
Honey, we can sing.
We know how you feel.
Who do you think you know?
Oh, no chance.
No way.
I won't say it, no no.
Yes I.
Why don't I?
Oh oh.
It's too cliche.
I won't say I'm in love.
I thought my heart had learned its lesson.
It feels so good when you're in love.
Oh, no chance, no way, I won't say you don't know.
Give up, give in, check the grin, you're in love.
Your scene won't play, I won't say I'm in love.
You'll lay your face, I won't say it.
Get off my case, I won't say it.
Girl, don't be proud, it's okay.
Well, at least I'll love.
I won't say I'm in love.
I should've had this, I should've, I should've...
I should've been like this the whole time.
Baby, don't, don't deny it.
We know how you're... how...
Oh my gosh, I saw someone else say something.
Actually, I'm just gonna do... a medley.
Maybe.
Say I'm in love.
Oh my gosh, you know what was so funny?
Before my stream yesterday with Ayami-sensei, when we were, when we were talking, um, we met about, uh...
Why are you...
You!
You're cute, aren't you?
Wow, thank you!
Thank you for singing for us tonight.
I hope you can sing some Disney songs tonight, but no...
Wow, virulent.
I think you're maybe...
Um, psychic.
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Oh, when we were, like, talking to...
When we were talking with each other, I was like, I was still preparing, um, OBS.
And she was just like, It's okay, take your time.
And I was just like, she was just like, We can tell them that we'll be a little bit late.
And I was like, yeah, you know, Um, they'll just start crying.
And she was just like, yeah, haha.
And then...
When it got time to start the stream, And everybody started crying.
And then she was just like, Oh, it's time.
Should we...
Are you almost ready?
I was like, yeah, I'm almost ready.
Just maybe a few more minutes.
Um, are they crying?
And she was like, ah...
She looked and she's like, ah, it's true.
Ah, they really are.
They really are crying.
It was so funny.
Yeah.
Um...
We were talking about silly stuff.
Um, I won't be streaming for the next couple of days.
Um...
So...
I'll stream...
I don't know how long today's stream will be.
We'll stream until my voice gives out.
But I also need to get ready as well.
But we'll...
We'll...
We'll sing until I cannot sing anymore.
So I'm gonna sing more Disney.
This song I've never sung before, but I really love this song.
So I think I'm gonna up the key.
Like a little...
Maybe 2.
And see how it goes.
Save behind these windows and these parapets of stone.
Gazing at the people down below me.
All of this live on some...
Hold on.
Before the history they show me.
That's kinda low.
Maybe I do need to lower the key.
Hold on, I'm going to lower the key.
I'll just try singing it normal.
All my life I've memorized their faces Knowing them as they will never know me After how it feels to pass the day Not above them But part of them And out there Living in the sun Give me one day out there All I ask is
A little pause... and
we are back.
Roofs and gables, I can see them Every day they shout and scold and go about their lives Heedless of the gift it is to be them If I was in their skin, I'd treasure Every instant out there Strolling by the sand Taste of morning out there Like ordinary men Who freely walk up out there Just one day and then I swear I'll be content With my share Won't resent,
won't despair Hold and bend, I won't care I'll have spent What I've got here out there
Oh.
God, I was not prepared for that.
Oh my.
I was not prepared.
Oh my God.
I'm sorry my voice cracked in that one part.
I'm so sorry my voice cracked.
I was not ready for that.
Oh my gosh, me being like, I don't want to sing some of the harder songs yet.
I need to warm my voice up first.
Sheesh.
Okay, this part.
This next song.
I'm going to skip the beginning.
I'm going to skip to here.
Speaking of hell, how about Hellfire?
I'm way ahead of you.
Beata Maria, you know I am a righteous man.
Of my virtue I am justly proud.
Beata Maria, you know I'm so much purer than the common vulgar, weak, licentious crowd.
Then tell me, Maria, why I see her dancing there?
Why her smoldering eyes still scorch my soul?
I feel her.
I see her.
The sun caught in her raven hair is blazing in me out of all control.
Like fire, hellfire, this fire in my soul.
This burning desire is turning me to sin.
It's not my fault.
I'm not to blame.
It is the gypsy girl, the witch who sent this flame.
It's not my fault.
If in God's plan, he made the devil so much stronger than a man.
Protect me, Maria.
Don't let this siren cast her spell.
Don't let her fire sear my flesh and bone.
Destroy Esmeralda.
And let her taste the fires of hell.
Or else let her be mine and mine alone.
Minister Frollo.
The gypsy has escaped.
Who are you?
Get out of my room.
She's no one in the cathedral.
No, what?
She's gone.
Oh, my God.
But how?
Um, go get my girlfriend back.
Uh, I'll find her if I have to burn down all of Paris.
Hellfire, dark fire.
Now, gypsy, it's your turn.
Choose me or your pyre.
Be mine or you will burn.
God have mercy on her.
God have mercy on me.
But she will be mine or she will burn.
escaped.
That song fills me with so much passion.
You know what, that's a go out there and get her guy kind of song, isn't it?
Ha ha ha ha.
Go out there!
That's a go get her song.
That's a... Yeah.
No it's not.
Oh, my gosh.
Villain songs are always so good, right?
Reccept?
Oh my gosh, I really dislike the one from Wish.
I don't remember how it even goes.
Actually, okay, you guys, give me a second.
You know that I recently got a standing desk?
And I believe I should stand this stream.
I hope when I use this, it doesn't turn off my computer.
I'm like worried that it's gonna like short circuit.
I'm gonna stand.
Oh, okay.
I'm lifting up my desk.
Oh, how high can this go?
Wow.
Okay.
Nice.
Standing time.
Oh my gosh, I have so much room to dance around.
Oh no, I'm gonna be so much more obnoxious now cause I'm gonna be...
actually like dancing around.
Gonna be dancing around for real.
Give me one second.
What is going on here?
There we go.
Make sure my phone's not on.
Okay.
What's the next song?
Actually, you know, can I do one more?
Hunchback of Notre Dame's song.
Are Hololive songs off limits for legal reasons?
No, but...
Hold on, I'm also gonna move my mic up.
Oh, setlist.
Thank you.
Out there.
And Hellfire.
Boy, it's one word.
But a lot of the Hololive songs are in Japanese.
And this is...
This is in English.
Oh, Sparks?
Wait.
Is there even a karaoke for Sparks?
Sparks Instrumental.
I'm not gonna bother Kiyo.
Kiara.
Wait.
Oh my god!
There is one.
Wait.
It says karaoke instrumental with lyrics.
Do you might be the...
Do you?
I don't know if I could sing them well, but I'll try.
Maybe later.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
One more Hunchback of Notre Dame song.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
Is it this one?
I'll do the shorter one.
I think it's the shorter one.
Danielle, welcome to membership.
And thank you guys for all the super chats too.
I'll make a man out of you.
Yes.
I'll do I'll make a man out of you.
No worries.
I'll do more Disney.
Sorry.
I'm a Disney fan.
I don't want to say the Disney adult.
That's embarrassing right?
I don't know if you can hear me.
Or if you're even there.
I don't know if you will listen.
To a humble prayer.
Tell me I'm just an outcast.
I shouldn't speak to you.
Still I see your face and wonder.
Were you once an outcast?
God help the outcasts, hungry from work, show them the mercy they don't find on earth.
The lost and forgotten, they look to you still.
God help the outcasts, or nobody will.
Why does this sound like the ending version?
It sounds different.
I ask for nothing, I can get by.
But I know so many less lucky than I.
God help the outcasts, the poor and down-drawn.
I thought we all were the children of God.
Listen, some are, and some are not.
Why the few you seem to favor.
The
outcasts, the tattered, the torn.
Seeking an answer to why they were born.
Winds of misfortune have blown them about.
You made the outcasts, don't cast them out.
I'm confused.
The poor and unlucky, the weak and the odd.
That's me.
I thought we all were the children of God.
I'm sorry, I'm so unserious.
I'm the odd.
Okay, I'm not even gonna put that on the set list.
I was so confused.
During that.
I thought I picked the shorter version because there's also a longer version.
But I don't remember the other parts of this.
Okay.
I love Hunchback of Notre Dame.
It's such an awesome movie.
There's a karaoke of the original version out there.
I'm sure there is, but...
Let's see.
Do you still remember the requests?
There were a ton.
What do you mean?
Remember?
There were so many requests.
Tarzan songs?
I don't know very many Tarzan songs because I didn't watch a lot of Tarzan.
Kendrick?
Kendrick Lamar song?
I don't even know that guy.
Has been hotel?
Those songs have bad words in it.
Has been hotel.
There's only actually one song from Has been hotel that I've listened to.
And it's...
I don't know.
I don't remember what it was called.
Stayed gone?
Maybe...
No.
There's a song between...
I don't know.
I've never watched it.
It's a song between the radio guy and the TV guy.
Kevin Lamar?
Oh.
Who's that?
Wait.
Stayed gone?
I was...
I was right?
Oh my god.
I'm scared though.
I'm showing the screen and if it says bad word, it's gonna show up.
Fulamukul Rivals.
That's the guy.
Who's Ken then?
Kevin
Lamar is what Fulamukul call...
Wait.
So his name is actually Kev...
Kevin.
His actual name is Kendrick.
Oh.
I see.
I always...
I always thought they were two different people because they were talking.
I've only seen...
I've seen Kendrick Lamar and I've seen Kevin Lamar.
I thought they were two different people.
I was like...
Wow.
There's a lot of rappers with the last name Lamar.
I was like...
Wow.
I didn't realize Lamar was such a popular last name.
I
was like...
Is this a bit?
I'm never serious.
What are you talking about?
Of course this is a bit.
Thanks for the peek!
Your unique voice and personality elevates every song you sing.
Sing your heart out.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Lamar isn't his last name?
What?
What does it mean?
Is it like a...
type of juice?
Please wrap it up.
Shut up!
Oh, it's a middle name!
His last name is actually Duxworth.
No, it's not.
Kevin Lamar Duxworth.
Duxworth is a song by...
Oh, no!
Kendrick Lamar!
It is!
It's real!
It's...
It's actually his last name!
Hold on.
A song by Kendrick Lamar...
Taken from his album...
Damn!
The song title is Lamar's actual last name.
What?
Who is Kendrick Lamar?
Oh!
He's just some guy.
I would also go...
No, he should have gone by Duxworth.
That's so much cooler.
What do you mean, some guy?
I don't know.
I'm just looking at him.
He just looks like a guy.
Am I looking at the right person?
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I typed Kevin.
Kendrick Lamar.
Actually, I'm going to look up Kevin Duxworth.
That's just...
Yeah.
Okay.
It would be kind of weird if he looked like a ghost.
I'm not expecting him to look like a ghost.
I'm just... I don't know.
I don't know what I'm expecting.
I'm expecting.
It's my birthday!
Happy birthday, Marty!
Happy birthday!
Was it my first Super Award?
Thank you!
Yeah, I kind of expected a duck.
To be honest.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Marty.
Happy birthday!
To be you!
Happy birthday to...
to you.
His dad's nickname was actually Ducky.
I wonder if this is on here.
Oh my gosh!
Life
is like a hurricane here in Duckburg.
Race cars, lasers, aeroplanes.
It's a duck blur.
Might solve a mystery or rewrite history.
DuckTales!
Every day they're out there making DuckTales.
When
it seems they're heading for the final curtain.
Cool deduction never fails.
That's for certain.
The worst of messes become successes.
DuckTales!
Every day they're out there making DuckTales.
There's a stranger out to find you.
What to do?
Just grab on to some DuckTales!
Oh
my god.
Yay!
Thank you for singing the song of my people.
I got you.
DuckTales!
Woo!
I was jumping all around the whole song.
Oh wait, did I do anything between Hellfire and...
Yeah, DuckTales.
DuckTales!
Woo!
Basically like doing jumping jacks.
Cause I'm like flapping my hands.
Okay.
That was so fun yo.
I'll one day sing it.
Maybe with 3D.
It's my birthday too which means this karaoke is specifically for me now since I am announcing it after the other guy.
Teemo!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Teemo.
How about some Little Mermaid for your newest subscriber?
Second newest now.
Little Mermaid I can do.
Little Mermaid.
Which song from the Little Mermaid?
What song should I do from the Little Mermaid?
I can do all of them.
No, I'm just kidding.
Under the sea.
Okay.
I'm gonna start dancing again.
You guys just want me to dance.
The seaweed is always greener.
In somebody else's lake.
Can I show you guys?
Can I show you how I feel when I'm singing these?
Hold on.
I have to get...
I have to get a TikTok that I sent to Matara.
But...
But it's actually maybe me.
I sent it to her and I was like, this is you.
But maybe it's me.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
Where is it?
I said this is you.
I'm gonna put it on the screen and then you can just imagine me looking like this while I'm singing.
Okay, okay.
But hold on.
I have to make sure you don't hear the audio.
Can I just...
Oh, download video.
Oh my god!
I can just download the video!
Oh wait.
It's gonna play the audio though.
I don't want you to hear the audio.
Uh...
Let's see.
How do I do this?
Maybe like this.
And then...
How do I do this?
I should turn the air on in my...
In my maid cafe.
It's so warm.
Mute it?
It's gonna play immediately.
I'm scared.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
How do I do this?
Sorry.
Sorry for...
Uh...
Let me have the stream for a minute.
No, it's because...
OBS is kinda messing me up right now.
Okay, hold on.
I got this.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Kind of.
Maybe.
No, I just wanna show you guys the silly video!
Oh, I just wanna show you the silly video!
Just wanna show you silly video.
Maybe audio filter.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I can do gain.
And then lower entirely.
So that there's nothing that plays.
Okay.
I'm really sorry if you hear this.
I'm really sorry!
Okay, okay.
I'm just gonna put it right here.
Okay, this is me.
This is me as I'm...
As I'm singing.
If you were trying to imagine music, If you were trying to imagine music, it's caramel dancing.
It's caramel dancing.
The seaweed is always greener Than somebody else's lake You dream about going up there You dream about going up there But that is a big mistake Just look at the world around you Right here on the ocean floor Such wonderful things around you What more is here looking for?
Under the sea!
Darling, it's better down where it's wetter Take it from me!
Up on the shore They work all day Out in the sun, they survive a wave While we double in full time To float in under the sea
Down here all the fish is happy As all through the waves they roll The fish on the land ain't happy They sat cosily in their pool But fish in the bowl is lucky But fish in the bowl is lucky They aim for a worse fate One day when the boss gets hungry Guess who's gonna be on the plate Uh oh!
Under the sea!
Nobody feed us fries And eat us and make us What would we learn To fully cook Under the sea we're off the hook We got no troubles Life is the bowels Under the sea, under the sea Under the sea, under the sea We hear, we got the beat here Naturally Even the surgeon and the ray They get the urge and start to play We got the spirit You got to hear it Under the sea The flute,
the carp play the harp The place play the bass And they sound and sharp The bass play the brass And trill play the tub The fluke is the duke of soul The ray he can play The lings on the strings
Oh where is that?
And oh that blowfish Maybe
a standing desk was a mistake
Under the sea Under the sea When the sardine begins The big greenie's music to me What do they got?
A lot of sand We got a hot Cressacean fan Each little clam here Know how to jump here Under the sea Each little slug here Caught in a rut here Under the sea Each little snail here Know how to wail here That's why it's hotter Under the water Yeah we in luck here Down in the muck here Under the sea Yeah
That's me That was me the entire song That little kid Including the falling on the floor And everything Yay
Be my guest Be Be our guest Got me groovin' and laughin' at work, didn't you know that?
This one.
Be our guest, be our guest.
Les poissons.
Les poissons, les poissons.
Something, something.
Les poissons.
Ma chrie, mademoiselle.
It is with deepest pride and greatest pleasure that we welcome you tonight.
And now we invite you to relax.
Let's relax.
Let us pull up a chair as the dining room proudly presents your dinner.
Be our guest, be our guest, put our service to the test.
Tie your napkin round your neck, chrie, and we'll provide the rest.
Soup de jour, hors de devour, we only live to serve.
Try the great stuff, it's delicious.
Don't believe me?
Ask the dishes.
They can sing.
They can dance.
After all, Miss, this is France.
And a dinner here is never second best.
Go on, unfold your men.
You take a glance, and then you'll be our guest.
We our guest.
Be our guest.
Be our good cheese to play.
Pie and pudding en flamb.
We'll prepare and serve with flair a culinary cabaret.
You're alone and you're scared, but the banquet's all prepared.
No, no, no, no, no.
No one's gloomy or complaining while the flatware's entertaining.
We tell jokes.
I do tricks.
With my fellow candlesticks.
And it's all in perfect taste that you can bear.
Come on and list your glass.
You've won your bone-free pass.
To be our guest.
If you're stressed, it's fine.
Dining, we suggest.
Be our guest.
Life is so unnerving.
For certain, you're only human.
It's just like me, I'm a maid.
Ah, the good old days when we were useful.
I don't remember this part.
Suddenly, those good old days are gone.
Ten years we've been rusting, needing so much more than dusting.
Needing exercise, a chance to use our skills.
Most days, we just lay around ze castle.
Flabby, fat, and lazy, you walked in and oops-a-daisy.
It's a guest, it's a guest, sakes alive, I'll be blessed.
Wine's been poured, and thank the Lord, I had the napkins freshly pressed.
With dessert, she'll want tea, and my dear, that's fine with me.
While the cups do their soft-shoe-in, I'll be blubbing, I'll be blub-blub-blubbing.
Heaven's sake, is that a spot?
Clean it up, we want the company impressed.
We've got a lot to do, is it one lump or two?
For you our guest, be our guest, she's our guest, be our guest.
Be our guest, be our guest, a command is your request.
It's been years since we've had anybody here, and we're obsessed.
With your meal, with your ease, yes indeed, we aim to please.
While the candlelight's still glowing, let us help you.
We'll keep going.
Worst by course, oh!
One by one, oh!
Till you shout, enough, I'm done!
Then we'll sing you off to sleep you as they're jealous.
Tonight you'll prop your feet up, but for now let's eat up.
Be our guest, be our guest, be our guest, please.
Be our guest!
Why are you making me sing all these heart songs?
Why are
you making me sing all these heart songs?
Oh wait, uh, I've missed, uh, Under the Sea.
And...
Be our guest, be our guest, ba-ba-ba ba-ba-ba-ba.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Oh my god, it's the whole time I was just thinking of the, of the ride at Tokyo Disney, so awesome.
Must be getting a workout tonight.
I am!
Take a break by singing tequila?
You're so right.
What does tequila taste like?
I've never had it before.
Rockbiter, thanks for the vibe!
Gifted!
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
Is it this one?
It's spicy?
Oh no!
I'm getting an itch in my body!
I'm dancing!
Oh no!
Tequila!
Who are you?
Careful not to strain your voice.
Yay.
Okay.
I'm all warmed up now.
It was two lovers Sitting in the car, listening to Blonde Falling for each other Pink and orange skies, feeling super childish No Donald Glover Missed call from my mother Like where you at tonight?
Got no alibi I was all alone with the love Of my life She's got glitter for skin My radiant beam In the night Look down I don't need no light To see you Shine
It's your Golden hour
You slow down time In your
We were just two lovers feet up on the dash driving nowhere fast burning through the summer radio on blast make the moment last she got solar power and it's feel like hours she knew she was the baddest can you even imagine falling like i did And for the love of my life,
she's got glow on her face, a glorious look in her eyes, my angel of light.
I was all alone with the love of my life, she's got glitter for skin, my radiant beam in the night.
I don't need no light to see you shine.
It's your golden time.
You slow down time.
In your golden time.
I forget how long the intro or the outro is.
I saw someone else request something earlier.
That I can sing.
Actually, I will do my best.
I will do my best to sing.
I think I've only sung this song once.
Hate to give you satisfaction, asking how you're doing now.
How's the castle built off people you pretend to care about?
Just like you wanted.
Look at you, cool guy.
You got it.
I see the parties and the diamonds sometimes when I close my eyes.
Six months of torture you sold as some forbidden paradise.
I loved you truly.
You gotta laugh at the stupidity.
Cause I've made some real big mistakes.
But you make the worst one look fine.
I should have known it was strange.
You only come out at night.
I used to think I was smart.
But you made me look so naive.
The way you sold me for parts.
Cause you sunk your teeth into me.
You're a bloodsucker.
Fame fucker.
Bleeding me dry like a goddamn bam.
And every girl I ever talked to told me you were bad, bad news.
You called them crazy.
God, I hate the way I called them crazy too.
You're so convincing.
How do you lie without flinching?
Oh, what a mesmerizing, paralyzing, fucked up little thrill.
Can't figure out just how you do it.
God knows I will never will.
Not for her.
Cause girls your age know better.
I've made some real big mistakes.
But you make the worst ones look fine.
I should have known it was strange.
You only come out at night.
I used to think I was smart.
But you made me look so naive.
The way you sold me for parts.
Cause you sunk your teeth into me.
You're a bloodsucker.
Fame fucker.
Bleeding me dry like a goddamn vampire.
You said it was true love.
But wouldn't that be hard?
You can't love anyone.
Cause that would mean you had a heart.
I tried to help you out.
Now I know that I can.
Cause now you think this kind of things I'll never understand.
I've made some real big mistakes.
But you make the worst ones look fine.
I should have known it was strange.
You only come out at night.
I used to think I was smart.
But you made me look so naive.
The way you sold me for parts.
Cause you sunk your teeth into me.
You're a bloodsucker.
Fame fucker.
Bleeding me dry like a goddamn vampire.
Yeah!
This is Vampire by Olivia Rodrigo.
Wait, what did I sing after Tequila?
Oh, Golden Hour?
And then...
Vampire?
English?
Olivia?
Not to be mistaken with the other?
Glad you're back, Min!
Since you're not streaming on Friday.
Could I get an early happy birthday?
Of course, table gnome!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear table gnome.
Happy birthday!
Happy early birthday.
Sorry, I won't be here to celebrate on the actual day.
But just play this on the actual day.
Actually, don't even listen right now.
Play it back on the original...
On the actual day.
The original day.
There's actually a song I want to sing.
I've never sung it before.
Okay.
Oh wait!
Actually, there's a couple songs I wrote down.
I remember someone saying this earlier.
I've never sung this song before, so I'm kind of nervous.
I'll do my best.
Oh.
I have lost it all And you don't seem the lying kind A shame that I can read your mind And all the things I bet I read there Candlelit smile that we both share And you know I don't mean to hurt you But you know that it means so much And you don't even feel the pain I am falling,
I am fading I am drowning, help me to breathe I am hurting, I have lost it all I am losing, help me to breathe
I am falling, I am failing, help me to breathe I don't know the ad-libs here.
I am falling, I am failing,
help me to breathe I am hurting, I am drowning, help me to breathe I have lost it all, I am losing, help me to breathe I have lost
it all, I am losing, help me to breathe
How do you say the name of this song?
Duvet?
I know it's French probably, right?
Duvet It's so crazy how this song kind of blew up recently But as I guess most maybe not maybe not most people nowadays but It's the opening of the anime Serial Experiments LANE Which I watched long long long ago Long long long ago Duvet like the blanket,
I don't know actually Maybe Let's all love LANE It's because of LANE
LANE LANE Serial Experiments LANE Now, okay Would love to hear you sing My First Lover by Gillian Welch The movie The Strangers got me into this song Oh, the one that creepy song that like plays over and over again on the...
Can we try Welcome to the Black Parade?
Let's do that later
Thank you Oh my gosh also Brick, I'm so sorry I just saw your Akadono Mint left heaven but she still sings like an angel No, thank you Thank you so much I'm sorry I missed it Arigato, arigato, chu
What was I gonna say?
Way to Fall, I could do Way to Fall No, I was gonna say something though Um...
Mariana Cross, I could do that one too Maybe my voice can handle it I don't remember, sorry My whole brain Chapleroad H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me Hot to go Hot Minto!
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Wait, H-O-T-M-I-N-T-O You can take me Hot Minto!
I wonder if there's any Final Fantasy on here Final Fantasy I sung some a while ago before Oh my god!
They have Stekidane!
But this song is in Jap- Wait, is it in Japanese?
I'm so curious I'm so curious right now I don't think I've ever sung a Japanese song on Cairofun So I'm like...
There's- There's not an English version of this song, is there?
I think
there's a- I'm gonna skip forward, I hope it's okay Actually, no This could be one Japanese song
Don't think twice This song is so hard I wonder if there's Utada Hikaru on here
Oh wait, I'm thinking of Chikai Chikai is really hard But don't think twice I could maybe do if it's on here Oh my god
Kase ga koshita kotoba ni Oyoida Kokoro Kumou ga hakobu ashita ni Kazunda koe I can't get the timing Tsuki ga yureru kagami ni Furuetta
A little pause... and we are back.
This
part is so pretty!
3,
2, 1
A voice, so far away
The moon flows through the mirror that blurs
The stars sway and fall
I can't hide these tears Cobo Mansion.
I like this part.
Oh my god!
Yay!
I could see it!
Oh my god, at the beginning I was like trying to...
I couldn't remember so much of it.
But then it all came back to me all at once.
I love Final Fantasy X and X-2.
They do have Utada Hikaru on here.
No,
they don't have...
What was Chikai called again?
Um...
They don't have it though.
No!
They do have Simple and Clean though.
Thousand Words.
I don't know if they had it though.
Final Fantasy X-2 songs.
Let me see if they have a Thousand Words.
No.
Sad.
Do they have...
What was the other one?
What can I do for you?
Melodies of Life.
No.
I think that was the only Final Fantasy song that they have.
So sad.
Wait, I wonder if I put in Kingdom Hearts.
Kingdom Hearts.
Oh wait, so if I put in Kingdom Hearts, the songs don't show up.
But if I put in Utada Hikaru, they do.
Eyes on Me.
I think I sang Eyes on Me last time.
Hmm.
A Sanctuary.
The English one.
Oh my gosh.
Utada Hikaru.
Blah blah blah.
Oh there it is.
It fixed itself.
Excuse me?
Excuse
me?
Excuse me?
Like the English one?
Like the English one.
A Sanctuary.
Ew.
I like it.
Or's it a Sanctuary.
Ew.
Ew wrong.
Eww!
Ew...
Ew.
I don't think I can sing this one very well, but that's okay.
Wonk.
It's so cool that they have the lyrics actually backwards.
What?
That's so awesome!
I forgot how hard this song goes.
Nothing is whole and nothing is broken.
And you and I, there's a new land.
My sanctuary, my sanctuary.
Yeah.
Where fears and lies melt away.
You leave me alone.
Why do you leave me alone?
What's left of me?
What's left of me now?
My
fears, my lies Felt away.
You left me alone.
This song is so hard to sing.
I believe that there are just some songs that Utada Hikaru can only sing.
Wonk.
Yay.
Request Eyes on Me from Final Fantasy 8.
I can probably find it somewhere.
I will find it.
Let's see.
I have to go to YouTube though.
I'm pretty sure I did Eyes on Me though.
Eyes on me.
Instrumenta.
Is there a...
Oh, here we go.
I think I did this one before.
Sorry, you'll just have to see...
You'll just see...
You'll just see Carofan but nothing else.
Nothing moving.
Not here.
And there's a letter.
I'm sorry about that.
It's just so beautiful.
You're welcome.
Bye-bye.
Have a nice day.
See you soon.
Bye -bye.
Bye.
Bye-bye.
Was it real or just my fantasy?
You'd always be there in the corner of this tiny little bar.
My last night here for you.
Same old songs, just once more.
My last night here with you.
Maybe yes, maybe no.
I kind of liked it your way.
How you shyly placed your eyes on me.
But did you ever know that I had mine on you?
Darling, so there you are.
With that look on your face.
As if you'd never heard.
As if you're never down.
Shall I be the one for you?
Who pinches you softly but sure?
If frown is shown then I will know that you are no dreamer.
So let me come to you.
Close as I want to be.
Close enough for me.
To feel your heart beating fast.
And stay there as I whisper.
How I loved your peaceful eyes on me.
Did you ever know that I had mine on you?
Darling, so share with me.
Your love if you have enough.
Your tears if you're holding back.
Or pain if that's what it is.
How can I let you know?
I'm more than the dress and the voice.
Just reach me out then.
You will know that you are not dreaming.
Darling, so there you are.
With that look on your face.
As if you'd never heard.
As if you're never down.
Shall I be the one for you?
Who pinches you softly but sure?
If frown is shown then I will know that you are no dreamer.
The song is so long.
Yay.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Don't listen to that end.
Look.
Thanks.
Um.
Outro.
YouTube channel.
YouTube channel outro.
There's actually another song I want to sing.
It's not.
It is on Carafun but I want to show you.
Actually, maybe I should just do the Carafun version.
Maybe I should do.
But it's like, it'll ruin the mood I think.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to sing it and then I'm going to show you the Kara fun version.
I'm going to sing it and then I'm going to show you the Kara fun version.
Because it's so funny.
Okay.
Because I want you to hear it... I don't want you to hear it and like...
Or see the lyrics and then be like, what the hell?
And then I sing it and you're like, wait, it's already ruined.
Okay.
Song Kang!
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Holy shit.
Song Kang.
Oh my god, sorry.
That has an intro on the YouTube one.
Holy moly.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry, my...
I'm so sorry.
That hurt me as much as it hurt you guys, probably.
I'm so sorry!
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
It played it again?
But I turned it off.
Ah!
God, sorry.
You can't hear it, but I can.
Shut up!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Holy...
It's so loud, even for me!
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna sing.
The song is like, so not that type of song either, so it's funny.
Oh, you could hear it a little bit.
Day seems sometimes as if they'll never end.
Sun digs heels to haunt you.
But after sunlit days, one thing stays the same.
Rises the moon.
Days fade into a watercolor blur.
Memories swim and haunt you.
But look into the lake, shimmering like smoke.
Rises the moon.
Close your weary eyes.
I promise you that soon the autumn comes to darken fading summer skies.
Breathe, breathe, breathe.
Days pull you down just like a sinking ship.
Floating is getting harder.
But tread the water child and know that meanwhile rises the moon.
Days pull you up just like a daffodil.
A little pause...
and we are back.
I don't want there to be an outro.
This channel scares me.
Yay!
That was Rises the Moon.
Rises the Moon.
It's a really pretty song.
I think...
There's some other songs I want to sing.
We'll go back to Carrot Fun.
One of them is...
I saw some people requesting Carpenters.
Here you go.
Why do birds suddenly appear?
Every time you are near.
Just like me, they long to be.
Close to you.
Why do stars fall down from the sky?
Every time you walk by.
Just like me, they long to be.
Close to you.
On the day that you were born.
The angels got together.
And decided to create a dream come true.
So they sprinkled moon dust in your hair.
And golden starlight in your eyes of blue.
That is why.
All the girls in the town.
Follow you.
All around.
Just like me.
They long to be.
Close to you.
On the day that you were born.
The angels got together.
And decided to create a dream come true.
That is why.
All the girls in the town.
They long to be.
Close to you.
On the day
that you were born.
The angels got together.
And decided to create a dream come true.
So they sprinkled moon dust in your hair.
And golden starlight in your eyes of blue.
That is why.
All the girls in the town.
Follow you.
All around.
Just like me.
They long to be.
Close to you.
On the day that you were born.
The angels got together.
Just like me.
They long to be.
Close to you.
On the day that you were born.
And decided to create a dream come true.
That is why.
All the girls in the town.
They long to be.
On the day that you were born.
Close to you.
Remember I sing the song.
I hold my little baby snake.
And I sing to him.
Close to you.
A cheeky spirit on Twitter told me you are an enjoyer of Cultured Ren fan manga and I appear to say base.
Also, I forget how beautiful your singing is.
Thank you for the super chat!
Close to you.
I love you little snake.
Okay, go back to standing on my desk as you always are.
I got a snake from a gacha.
A snake figure.
And I sing to him every time.
Whether now or in the future, I think it would be real nice to hear you sing Don't Speak by No Doubt.
Even if it would be lethal.
Don't speak by no doubt.
Hopelessly devoted to you from Greece?
I've never sung that before.
Could you sing fine on the outside?
Oh, I can!
Wait, hold on.
Let me hear the Don't Speak.
Do I know this song?
No.
You
and me We used to be together Every day together Always I really feel That I'm losing my best friend I can't believe this could be The end It looks as though
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause... and we are
back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Oh my god, I haven't heard this song forever.
It's not ending.
Stop pretending.
Who we are.
I don't know this part.
Oh my god.
I have not heard this song in so long.
So I don't remember it very well.
I'm sorry.
You and me.
And I can see us dying.
Are we?
Don't speak.
I know just what you're saying.
So please stop explaining.
Don't tell me cause it hurts.
No, no.
Don't speak.
I know what you're thinking.
And I don't need your reasons.
Don't tell me cause it hurts.
I know what you're saying.
So please stop explaining.
Don't speak.
Oh.
I know what you're thinking.
And I don't need your reasons.
I know you're good.
I know you're real good.
Oh.
La la la.
Lush.
Darling.
Yay.
Let's see.
I did...
Close to you.
Don't speak.
Um.
You're singing my karaoke song.
Sorry if I...
Butchered it then.
Hush, hush.
Push, push.
Kiss from a rose.
Oh my gosh.
Have I ever sung this song before?
I don't think so.
I met Seal.
No, not Seal.
Wait...
A Seal!
A SEAL.
I think I'm confusing artists.
Silly guys.
You remember me by Juul.
I don't know if I know that one.
I hope he didn't know.
David
Matik.
American Idol.
Once upon a time...
And you became the light on the dark side of me And love remained way at your heart That's the heart, not the pill But did you know that when it snows My eyes become larger The light that you shine can be seen Baby, I compare you to a kiss from a rose On the gray Ooh,
the more I get of you The stranger it feels, yeah And now that your rose is in bloom A light hits the gloom On the gray What does that mean?
A kiss from a rose on the gray?
What's the gray?
I don't understand it.
There's so much a man can tell you So much he can say You remain my power My pleasure, my pain Baby, to me you're like a growing addiction I can't even deny Won't you tell me is it the healthy baby?
Oh wait, but did you know That when it snows My eyes become larger The light that you shine can be seen Baby, I compare you to a kiss from a rose On the gray Ooh, the more I get of you The stranger it feels, yeah And now that your rose is in bloom A light hits the gloom On the gray She's basically deep.
What do you mean by that?
It's meant to be abstract.
A
kiss from a rose on the gray A kiss from a rose on the gray A kiss from a rose on the gray A kiss from a rose on the gray There is so much a man can tell you Oh gosh, I don't remember this.
He can say You remain my power My pleasure, my pain Baby, to me you're like a growing addiction I can't even deny Won't you tell me is it the healthy baby?
Oh wait, but did you know That when it snows My eyes become larger The light that you shine can be seen Baby, I compare you to a kiss from a rose On the gray Ooh, the more I get of you The stranger it feels, yeah And now that your rose is in bloom A light hits the gloom On the gray Yes,
I compare you to a kiss from a rose On the gray Ooh, the more I get of you The stranger it feels, yeah And now that your rose is in bloom A light hits the gloom On the gray This isn't about drugs, is it?
Now that your rose is in bloom A light hits the gloom On the gray
Drugs?
No!
It's about kissing roses.
Obviously!
Most common views are either touching the edge of death Or the rose bringing back vibrance to life that was depressive and gray.
See, that sounds so nice!
It's about love, I think.
Yeah.
See?
Gosh, you guys.
It's about love.
Is it about anything?
Who knows?
What time is it?
I've only been... I've sung 22 songs in...
2 hours?
That's so many.
Hold on.
I'm gonna eat some more of my food.
I hope it's okay.
Let's take a little break.
Let's take a little tiny break.
Let me eat.
Break time!
So I can eat my food.
Yeah, this will be archived.
Don't worry.
You're like, I wanna go watch something else.
Yeah, I get it.
I don't want you to hear me.
Hold on.
I'm like eating it so fast.
I'm eating it so fast.
My tummy started to growl though.
You know what?
Don't watch me eat either.
I'm gonna turn around.
There we go.
Now you can't listen to me.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm gonna stand away from the light.
Okay.
Probably.
She moves away from the mic to breathe.
Her 4 was your lucky number.
Thanks!
Chocolate Rain Some Say...
Is that true that song is about pooping?
Is it true that song is about pooping?
I hope not...
I got some broccoli on my desk.
Okay.
See you tomorrow.
Into the trash!
There we go.
I think you can sing six... wait...
Kiss me by sixpence none the richer.
Yeah, I can sing that one.
Chocolate rain isn't about pooping, it's not?
I don't know, I just remember hearing that as a kid.
People were like, some stay dry while others feel the pain.
Chocolate rain.
It's about what?
Oh, I think I'm way off.
I
only know the chocolate rain.
My bad.
I didn't mean to be insensitive.
I just had no idea.
I regret my words in action.
I regret my words in action, my words and deeds.
Fabulous from High School Musical 2?
Oh my gosh, I don't know if I...
I don't know if I know it very well.
That's the one that goes...
I'm feeling fabulous.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Fabulous.
That's the one.
I don't know what.
Is this archived?
I don't know.
Maybe not anymore.
Well.
No, I'm just kidding.
What was I gonna do?
I wonder if... I wonder if this is on here.
No, I'm gonna have to find an instrumental on YouTube.
Let me check if this one works.
Sorry, you're gonna hear no music.
I think so.
I don't hear some awful, terrible intro or anything, so let's do this one.
Okay.
Okay!
Calliope Mori's End of a Life.
There's a karaoke version.
Oh!
I don't know though.
I like that song a lot.
I've never tried singing it.
I'm so nervous to sing... to sing other YouTuber songs sometimes.
I'll think about it though.
Maybe one day I'll do like a dedicated Hololive karaoke.
Maybe I'll do a dedicated Hololive karaoke sometime.
Because I've been singing a lot of Stellar Stellar.
I've been singing so... or not singing, but like listening to Stellar Stellar so much.
Calli won't mind.
I don't know.
I'm afraid of upsetting people.
So... I don't know.
If I do upset people, I would at least do the songs justice, you know?
Hmm.
We'll see.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
I'm gonna write a few more of this... some of the requests that I've seen.
That I'm thinking of.
Um... actually...
Now I'm... now I can't remember any of it.
You know what?
Let's just... we'll just... we'll just play by ear.
Okay.
Oh!
I started playing it, but you guys couldn't hear it.
There we go.
Okay.
I never had that many friends growing up, so I learned to be...
Okay with just me.
Just me.
And I'll be fine on the outside.
I like to eat in school by myself.
Anyway.
So I'll just stay...
Right here.
And I'll be fine on the outside.
So I just say...
I'll just sit in my room after hours with the moon.
And think of who knows my name.
Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
So
I left home, I packed up and I
asked one day.
And I laughed.
I laughed.
I
sound fine on the outside.
Ooh.
I'm
lost.
Sometimes I'm confused.
Sometimes I find that I am not alright.
And I cry.
And I...
So I just sit in my room after hours with the moon.
And think of who knows my name.
Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
That one's kind of hard to sing.
Fine on the outside.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Another one that people were asking for.
Oh!
There was one that I wanted to sing.
How do I...
Oh, it's a...
What's it called?
Hold on.
I have it.
The tippy, tippy, tippy, tippy of my tongue.
Oh!
Maybe if I search this.
Okay.
I've never actually seen Steven Universe before.
But I really like the music.
So I'm going to sing this one next.
If I could begin to be half of what you think of me.
I could do about anything.
I could even learn how to love.
When I see the way you act.
Wondering when I'm coming back.
I could do about anything.
I could even learn how to love.
Like you.
Love like you.
I
always thought I might be bad.
Now I'm sure that it's true.
I think you're so good.
And I'm nothing like you.
Look at you go.
I just adore you.
I wish that I knew.
What makes you think I'm so special.
If I could begin to do something that does right by you.
I would do about anything.
I would even learn how to love.
When I see the way you look.
Shaken by how long it took.
I could do about anything.
I could even learn how to love like you.
Love me like you.
This song is so pretty.
Oh my god.
Love like you.
Yay!
Let's see.
There's... I don't know this other one though.
But I like it.
I know it a little bit but I might mess up the middle part.
I'm gonna try it anyway.
If I mess it up, sorry.
I was fine.
With the men.
Who would come into our life now and again.
I was fine.
Cause I knew.
That they didn't really matter until you.
I was fine.
When you came.
And we fought like it was all some silly game.
Over her.
Who'd she choose?
After all those years.
I never thought I'd lose.
It's over.
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
It's over.
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
You won.
And she chose you.
And she loved you.
And she's gone.
It's over.
Isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
War and glory.
Reinvention.
Fusion.
Freedom.
Her attention.
Out in daylight.
My potential.
Bold.
Precise.
Experimental.
Who am I now in this world without her?
Petty and dull.
With the nerve to doubt her.
What does it matter?
It's already done.
Now I've got to be there for a sign.
It's over.
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
It's over.
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
You won.
And she chose you.
And she loved you.
It's over, isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
It's so Jover.
It's Jover, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it Jover?
It's Jover, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Thank you!
I'm on a flight to Colombia!
Wow, how fun!
I want to thank you for inspiring me to visit new places and get out of my comfort zone!
Can you sing Shakira or any songs from Encanto?
Thank you for always being amazing!
I don't know if I know very many Shakira songs that well, but I can sing Encanto!
Encanto...
What's a song that I could sing?
It's Fantover!
I think maybe the best thing I could do is we don't talk about Bruno, maybe.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Why did you make me cry in the middle of my work?
Don't cry!
Oh...
I only really know...
We don't talk about Bruno and the family Madrigal.
But I don't think I could sing that one very well because it's kind of fast.
I've never sung it before.
We don't talk about Bruno.
I'm going to sing all the parts.
Oh my God!
Hi!
Thank you for the 50s!
Thank you!
About Bruno, no, no, no, no.
We don't talk about Bruno.
But...
It was my wedding day.
We were getting ready...
Wait, hold on.
Oh, there.
There's a cloud in the sky.
There's a cloud so loud in the sky.
Bruno walks in with a mischievous grin.
I'm there.
You're telling the story, aren't I?
I'm sorry, mi vida, go on.
Bruno said it looks like rain.
What did he tell us?
In doing so, he floods my brain.
I wanna kiss the umbrella.
Married in a hurry.
Again.
What a joyous day.
But anyway.
We don't talk about Bruno.
No, no, no, no.
Hey!
Grew to live in Peru.
Bruno started stumbling.
I can always hear him sort of mumbling.
I associate with...
I messed it up.
I couldn't remember.
It's a heavy lift with the gifts so humbling.
Always left the abuela and the family fumbling.
Grappling with the prophecies they couldn't understand.
Do you understand?
Seven-foot frame.
Rats so long as back.
When he calls your name.
I forgot that part was coming up.
It all faced the black.
Yeah, he sees your dreams.
And freestyles your screams.
We don't talk about Bruno.
No, no, no, no.
He told me my fish would die.
Excuse me.
Oh, no.
He told me I'd be dead.
He said Bruno grew a gun.
And just like he said.
He said no.
All my hair would disappear.
Now look at my head.
No, no.
Your fate is sealed when your prophecy is read.
He told me that the life of my dreams would be promised and someday be mine.
He told me that my power would grow like the grapes that thrive on the vine.
He said Bruno grew a gun.
He told me that the man of my dreams would be just out of reach but drove to another it's like I hear him now it's like I hear him now I can hear him now Bruno yeah about that Bruno I really need to know about Bruno give me the truth and the whole truth Bruno No,
Isabella, your boyfriend's here!
Da-da!
He told me that the life of my dreams would be promised and someday be mine He told me that my power would grow like the grapes that thrive on the vine He told me that the life of my dreams would be promised and someday be mine He told me that my power would grow like the grapes we talk about Bruno Oh my
god.
This song is so crazy towards the end.
Thank you for the donut.
Superman my goldfinger, spiderwebs by no doubt, or centaria by sublime Maybe next time... I don't know if I... Maybe I would have to hear them and I would know.
Next time.
I will make a note of those.
Bruno... Bruno...
We don't talk about Bruno, no We don't talk about Bruno We don't talk about... about...
Bruno... Wait...
We don't talk about...
Mint singing Bruno
Scared by Roy Orbison Or not... Or not that...
Maybe the Phantom of the Opera The Phantom of the Opera!
Duh...
The Opera...
Which song from Phantom of the Opera?
Hmm...
I did All I Ask of You last time.
The Phantom... Mint Phantom of the Opera What about the song from Over the Garden Wall?
Um...
I don't know if it's on here.
I'll check.
Will He Joji?
Oh!
I only know one Joji song.
Music of the Night
Point of No Return?
No!
That song is too sexy!
How does this go?
High
time sharpens Heightens each sensation Darkness wakes and Stirs imagination Silently the senses Abandon their defenses Helpless to resist The notes I write Fork I compose The music of the night Is this sung by Phantom?
Slowly...
Gently...
Night unfurls its splendor Grasp it...
Sends it...
Tremulous...
And tender...
Hearing is believing Music is deceiving Hard as lightning Soft as candlelight Dare you trust The music of the night Close your eyes For your...
Tell the...
Tell the truth And the truth is...
Oh my god, my mic is peaking.
...Seal In the dark it...
Is here to...
...Pretend Time...
Is wanted...
...Onto me
Softly...
...Deafly...
...Music shall caress you Hear it...
Feel it...
...Sacrantly possess you Open up your mind Let your fantasies unwind In this darkness which you know You cannot find The darkness of the...
...Music of the night Through
a strange new world Leave all thoughts of the world you knew before Close your eyes and let music set you free Oh, not a good...
Not the best...
Only then...
...You can you...
...Belong to me ...
Ugh...
Glower widely...
Falling...
Sweet intoxication...
Touching...
Trusting...
Savor...
...Reach...
...Then sin...
...Destination...
Let the dream begin Let your darker side give in To the power of the music that I write The power of the music of the night
Oh!
Gosh!
What is this?
Oh my arms!
There's gonna be a episode ...
Congratulations...
...At last...!
Um...
I'm trying to speak Um...
Wait, hold on.
I want to hear that one.
When it says, help me, all I can think of is, help me white girl.
Yes!
We can go back to Disney.
I like singing like things obviously that I like to sing.
But it's also really fun to sing.
Like, you know, I sing Phantom of the Opera, I feel, pretty often.
I've never sung Music of the Night before, so it's kind of fun.
Make a man out of you.
Make a wisp out of you.
Well, hi Raiders!
Thank you!
Let's get down to business.
Defeat the Huns.
Did they send me daughters when I asked for sons?
You're the saddest bunch I ever met.
But you can bet, before we're through.
Mr. Al, make a man out of you.
Tranquil as a forest, but on fire within.
Once you find your center, you are sure to win.
You're a spineless, pale, pathetic lot, and you haven't got a clue.
Somehow I'll make a man out of you.
Out of you.
I'm never gonna catch my breath, single by those who knew me.
Boy, was I a fool in school for cutting gym.
Shut the hell up, this is my part!
This guy's got him scared to death.
Hope he doesn't see right through me.
Now I really wish that I knew how to swim.
Be a man.
We must be swift as the coursing rhythm.
With all the force of great time.
Be a man.
With all the strength of a raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
Time is racing toward us, till the Huns arrive.
Heed my every order, and you might survive.
Survive.
You're unsuited for the rage of war.
So pack up, go home, you're through.
How could I?
Be a man.
We must be swift as the coursing rhythm.
With all the force of a great time.
Be a man.
With all the strength of a raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
We must be swift as the coursing river.
With all the force of a great typhoon.
With all the strength of a raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
Yeah!
Oh no, I started to dance again.
Oh no!
I couldn't see who rated me because I think YouTube glitched it like...
Only showed like a white bar at the top.
So, thank you whoever rated, thank you!
Um, hold on, I need a drink of water.
The moon!
Okay, that was so fun.
Oh, I just wanna sing and dance now.
Um, I'll make a man out of you!
Actually, there's another song that I wanna do.
But I always fuck up the last part.
Oh, sorry.
I always mess up the last part.
Dancing Queen!
Oh my god, wait, actually I'll do that instead.
You're so smart!
Oh my gosh, you're so smart!
Twilight by ELO?
Okay, I'll sing that after.
oh
my gosh.
You can dance, you can...
...jazzing
queen!
Yay!
You've got to look for a king.
I'm
young and the music's high.
With a bit of rock music, everything's...
And when you get the chance, you are the dancing queen!
You are the dancing queen!
I can't sleep forever, 17.
Dancing queen.
Feel the beat from the tambourine.
Oh yeah.
See that ghost.
Watch that scene.
Diggin' the dancing queen.
You're
in the mood for a dance.
And when you get the chance.
You are the dancing queen.
Young and sweet.
Forever 17.
Dancing queen.
Feel the beat from the tambourine.
Oh yeah.
Watch that scene.
Diggin' the dancing queen.
I feel like I needed that baby video again.
Hold on, I'm going to pull it up.
I'm going to pull up the baby.
Hold on, where is it?
Where did I put it?
Baby video.
That's me.
Someone requested Twilight by ELO.
Okay.
This is me.
Dancing to Twilight by ELO.
Um, there it is.
I think I need to put this one...
No, I'll just sing it out the regular key.
Do Linkin Park?
Oh my gosh, I'll do Linkin Park after.
This is a good idea.
The vision's dancing in my mind.
The early dawn, the shades of time.
Twilight's crawling through my window.
No pain.
Am I awake or do I dream?
The strangest pictures I have seen.
Night is day and Twilight's gone away.
With your head held high and your silence large.
You can do what you mean from the open skies.
It's either real or it's a dream.
There's nothing that is in between.
Twilight.
I only meant to stay a while.
I gave you time.
To steal my mind.
Away
your face.
You disappeared without a trace.
You brought me here but can you take me back?
Inside the image of your light.
That now is day and once was night.
And this is the second one.
And this is the third
one.
This ending always toss me off.
I just turned around and was like... is something behind me?
The ending is so jarring...
Yay, that was Twilight!
Thank you for your energy...
Yeah!
I'll sing a few more songs.
Someone said Linkin Park.
Oh my gosh, now I'm like, oh no, I'm going to get into the emo song mood.
I know this stream is never going to end.
I'm going to do my favorite Linkin Park song, so I hope you don't mind.
I don't think I'll even be able to sing it well, but...
Like opening the wound up,
you all assume I'm safe here in my room, unless I try to start again I don't want to be the one the battles always choose Cause inside I realize that I'm the one confused I don't know what's worth fighting for, why I have to scream I don't know why I instigate Say what I don't mean I don't know how I got this way I know it's not alright So I'm breaking the habits I'm breaking the habits Tonight!
Where's the anime background?
I'm right here!
Clutching my cure I tightly lock the door I try to catch my breath
I'm getting my memories right The only reason I don't want to be on the living room Is to leave this place Because I know I'm going to have to stop Why I have to scream I don't know why I instigate Say what I don't mean I don't know how to get away I don't know how I got this way.
I'll never be alright.
So I'm breaking my habits.
I'm ready to
show you what I mean.
I don't know how I got this way.
I'll never be alright.
So I'm breaking...
This song is so awesome.
Yay!
That was Breaking the Habit.
From Linkin Park.
Let's see.
I feel like I sang like the Kidz Bop version of it though.
I feel like I sang the Kidz Bop version of it.
I'm like, I'll break it on the wall!
Or I'll paint it on the wall!
Lilium.
I don't know Latin.
Is it even on here?
Let's see.
Not on here.
I saw some people say Fleetwood Mac.
I don't remember which...
I'll try.
Um...
Let Biscuit break stuff.
I'm getting there!
Gosh!
Maybe this one.
It's totally different.
You know what?
This is all whiplash so it's fine, right?
This is all whiplash.
Oh, I forgot to add the dancing queen.
Thank you.
Oh, she's beautiful.
Oh, I forgot to add the dancing queen.
Thank you.
This one is called Oh My Gosh.
And I saw my reflection on the snow-covered hills, till the landslide brought me down.
Oh mirror in the sky, what is love?
Can the child within my heart rise above?
No, it's all about love.
Can I sail through the changing ocean tides?
Can I handle the seasons of my life?
Afraid of changing cause I've built my life around you But time makes you bolder, even children get older I'm getting older too
This is not the one I meant to pick.
Cause I don't know it as well.
But that's okay.
Afraid of changing cause I've built my life around you But time makes you bolder, even children get older I'm getting older too
And if you see my reflection in the snow-covered hills Well, the landslide brings me down If you see my reflection in the snow-covered hills Well, the landslide brings me down Oh, the landslide brings me down Hopefully I did it okay.
Hopefully I did that okay.
Yeah, but...
Landslide...
Gonna have to start scooting things up a little bit.
Yay.
Feels great?
Thank you.
Thank you for the claps, everybody.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Shut up and dance?
I always end dancing.
Bravo brings tears to my boomer eyes.
That was beautiful.
Thank you for donating mid-song.
How dare you.
No, I'm just kidding.
Don't worry about it.
I'm sad now.
Don't be sad.
Here's another one.
I'm probably gonna botch this one too.
Actually, I'm debating whether I want to sing it or not.
I think I'm gonna do three more...
I'm gonna go to 35.
So...
Thank you.
What about I'm Still Standing?
Oh, I like that one.
You know what?
I'm still standing...
Oh, I wrote sanding.
I'm really glad you did, Lansai.
I'm going to suggest it and it turned out beautifully.
Oh, thank you.
Is that Elton John?
Oh, I needed more water after this.
Oh.
So it never would.
Well, look at me.
I'm coming back again.
I got it.
Yeah.
I'm still standing.
I actually am still standing.
I'm...
I put my desk up, but I've been standing this whole time.
I've been standing since...
DuckTales!
No.
Yes?
I don't know.
About... about then.
I'm still standing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Some people are requesting Ghost.
I'll be honest.
Mariana Cross...
is like...
Call Me A Poser.
It's like one of the only songs that...
I've listened to a couple of their songs.
But it's only...
Probably the only one that I can sing so well.
Actually, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna go get some water.
Like super duper fast.
Super duper quick.
I'm like...
When I say it's quick, I'm gonna be like quick, quick.
So...
Don't...
Don't go anywhere.
Why are you guys crying?
I told you I was getting water.
What happened?
Why are you crying?
I'm crying!
Mmm.
Why are you crying?
Someone said, so no Snake Eater?
I don't know.
I have 3 songs left?
What are you talking about?
I have several songs left.
I have songs left.
Okay?
Oh my gosh.
I need to get ready for tomorrow.
Wait, I need to get ready for this weekend.
Oh, shoot.
Oh shoot.
Okay, I just noticed the time.
Okay.
I have...
Wait, two songs left.
I can do three if I feel like it.
Okay, let's do Snake Eater now then.
Well, I
have to find the one that is good.
Okay.
Okay,
let's do Snake Eater.
let's do Snake Eater now then.
Snake Eater
I'm still in a dream Snake Eater
Snake Eater Thank you, Andy Murray for your karaoke.
Oh, sorry.
The Phantom X.
Oh, perfect.
You're a phantom.
You're a phantom too.
Snake...
Snake Eater.
Okay.
I know what the next three songs will be.
Thank you guys for the super chats.
Oh my gosh, YouTube is like really breaking.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
I can't see anything.
Wait.
Oh.
Hold on.
Everything is breaking.
No.
Don't break, please.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Slade once again.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh.
Never get tired of hearing you singing that.
I'm glad.
I'll never get tired of singing it.
I don't know if I'm going to be able to sing this next one.
Because I think my throat is already borked.
And...
Do you want me to send you the kazoo instrumental when I'm done?
Oh my gosh.
Yes.
Of course.
Break it more.
Don't worry.
Break is happening.
But you know what?
I'm going to sing this anyway because I like this song.
Actually, hold on.
Wait.
I don't want to do it here.
There was actually a version I saw that said it had some special stuff.
Hold on.
Sorry.
You can just pretend it's playing, right?
You can just be like, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me check this real quick.
Oh.
It sounds like poo poo.
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm going to do this version.
Okay.
To sound Just is What?
What?
It Was It What?
Mary on a cross, if you choose to run away with me, I will tickle you internally.
And I see nothing wrong with that.
We were searching for reasons to play by the rules.
But we quickly found out it was just for fools.
Not for all the sorrow, we'll be riding high.
And the truth of the matter is, I'll never let you go, let you go.
You go down just like Holy Mary.
Mary on a, Mary on a cross.
Not just another bloody Mary.
You go down just like Holy Mary.
Mary on a, Mary on a cross.
Your beauty never ever scared me.
If you choose to run away with me, I will tickle you internally.
And I see nothing wrong with that.
You go down just like Holy Mary.
Mary on a cross.
Mary
on a cross.
You go down just like Holy Mary.
Mary on a cross.
I don't know why, but you wanna justify RIPPING SOMEONE THAT OFF No human contact, and if you interact Your life is on contract Your best bet is to STAY AWAY MOTHERFUCKER It's just one of those days It's all about the he says she says Bullshit I think you better quit Let shit slip Or you'll be leaving with a fat lip It's all about the he says she says Bullshit I think you better quit Talk of that shit It's just one of those days Feeling like a freight train First ones hit the plane,
leads to the blood stain Damn right I'm a maniac, you better watch your back Best
bet is to stay away MOTHERFUCKER I
think you better quit Let shit slip Or you'll be leaving with a fat lip It's all about the he says she says Bullshit
I feel like shit My suggestion is to keep your distance Cause right now I'm dangerous I've felt like shit I've been treated like shit All those motherfuckers That wanna step up Chainsaw Chainsaw And if my day keeps going this way I just might break something tonight I'll pack a chainsaw I'll skin your ass red
Talk of that shit So come and get it Yay Yay Oh wait, I already wrote it.
Hang on, across...
Break stuff...
And now the last...
Last... last... last song.
I accidentally hit my mic.
When I was...
When I was like, headbanging.
Oopsie.
Well thanks for being here for my karaoke everybody.
I have one last song.
And...
I hope you liked Break Stuff.
I know people have been asking for it a lot for some reason.
But...
I hope it...
Was your expectations...
Wait, I hope it...
I hope it...
Lived up to your expectations.
You went kind of crazy with that one.
It's such a good...
Song to just let it all out.
You know?
Yeah, thanks for the gift.
You guys, thank you for the...
Thank you for the donuts.
Thank you for the super chats.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Hold on.
I'm afraid of how that sounded.
To be honest, but...
I'm just...
Sometimes I listen back on my karaoke to see like...
Oh, I should adjust this.
Or change that.
Or whatever, whatever.
I don't think I'm gonna listen back...
To this one.
I don't think I'm gonna listen back to this one.
Okay.
Actually, that's 35 songs.
Maybe we should keep it at 35.
An even number.
Not even, but you know.
A clean number.
Just wait until you see me...
Sing that song in 3D.
I think...
It might be...
You know...
It might be really funny to watch.
Oh, man.
So... Oh!
My chat just broke.
Okay.
What you got against 36, huh?
Fine.
I guess we'll just do it.
Even though my throat hurts a little bit.
What?
My throat hurts?
That'd be crazy.
No!
I can keep going!
The emo anthem...
Has begun!
When I was a young ghost My father Took me into the city To see A marching band He said Son, when You grow up Would you be The savior of the broken The beaten And the damned He said Will you defeat them Your demons And all the non-believers The plans That they have made Because One day I'll leave you Mint phantom To lead you in the summer To join the Black Parade
I feel
like I should go And through it all To rise upon The bodies in the streets And when you're
listened to Reeling from decimated dreams
I salute to you all.
Thank you for watching!
Thank you for hanging out with me!
I'll see you guys in a couple of days!
But thank you for listening!
Thank you!
Bye!
I need a shower!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Oh, how do I...
Oh, there we go.
My chat is so broken.
I'm refreshing.
I didn't even see what you guys were...
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much!
Thank you guys!
See you later!
Bye-bye!
Oh my gosh, I didn't even say bye-bye.
Valentine, thank you for the $50 gift!
David Steele, thank you for the $50 gift!
Oh my gosh, Valentine, thank you for...
I think I said it earlier.
Bye-bye!
Sorry, I'm just...
Wait!
I love your voice so much!
You make my day so happy!
Thank you!
I always end up doing Welcome to the Black Parade.
I'm like...
My voice is just so...
But,
way of saying, I just shouldn't...
Oh my god, I can't even...
Oh no, I can't even end the stream!
Uh-oh.
Wait, hold on.
YouTube is broken!
Forever stream now!
Okay.
Thank you, guys!
Oh, Rick, thank you for the $50!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Casey!
Thank you for the $5!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Bye
-bye!
Bye -bye!
Bye -bye.